I think developing a game is a creative process like writing a novel
I have studied literature and history as well
You can use vulgar statements to describe the date when you want to be funny
And when it wants to distinguish between old events and contemporary events
I think the same relationship applies to software development and story writing
You specify the item names
You define the logic that connects the elements
This is a lot like writing a sentence
I have developed "Reigns" in my home and on my PC
The first release was released the week my son was born
I was happy at the time
The development of the game "Reigns" took 9 months
Such as the usual period of pregnancy
The work was hard
My life changed with the birth of my son
I wanted to be influential in this world
Working as a freelance game developer lets you do that
It is very easy to work alone
But not so games are developed
You can not design every small part
You must have the skill to show your business to people
Thus gaining a new perspective and new ideas
This is very important
Your ability to experience new things makes you free
So that you can work in the area you love
You can work with people from all over the world
And when I reflect on what I did in a short time
I am very excited to continue the work
The idea of ​​"Reigns" is a combination of "Tinder" and "Game of Thrones"
Swipe with your finger to start the adventure
We have relied so much on imagination.
Reading a few words and a few sentences
You should be able to imagine yourself as king.
I think the first time I was satisfied with the game
When I saw a user of the game he was laughing while playing
And then I knew that we had made something innovative
Google Play helped us succeed
And to promote the game in the most important times
And that the game will receive 1.5 million downloads.
So the Google Play standalone competition was great.
It is important to try things to advertise yourself.
You get the most out of every opportunity you have.
The development of mobile games is still fairly new.
We know that the game users have become passionate about it.
They want more stories and better ideas.
We are still exploring what we can offer.